hello hello testing okay good sorry for
the slight delay we had a network
connectivity issue but we are on now so
well
I am Damian this is David Fowler David
yeah we are from the a spinet team at
Microsoft today we're gonna do a talk on
signal are a little bit different to the
talks with are in the past we're kind of
challenging ourselves what Dave is
challenging himself really I've got the
easy job to do something that we're not
particularly familiar with which it'll
be fun but it's we're gonna use it as a
teaching and learning exercise to
hopefully let you walk away with a bit
more information about how signal hour
works under the covers and what has
driven some of the recent expansion in
how you can use signal I was just kind
of cool especially in these new sort of
cloud focused scenarios so very quick
refresh on what signal are is I'm
assuming I shouldn't assume but does
everyone here know what signal is who
who is used signal are before excellent
okay well we're gonna do a quick refresh
because you know it's been what six
years now I think we've had a version of
signal herb that's been shipped but
we've gone through two major revisions
we've got the sort of classic signal our
phrase Fannett and then the 8-minute
core signal our which came out was a
year and a half two years eighteen point
one point one so what is it well we've
got to changed how we talk about it we
used to talk about incredibly simple
real-time web for net which I think I
coined six years ago but now you know
we've moved on the industry's a bit
different we care about other things and
so what is signal are it's a framework
for duplic duplex RPC and and streaming
between client and server there's lots
of other RPC frameworks like we add a G
RPC support needs Bennett core three but
signal I still has some unique
capabilities especially the server push
element which you don't get from things
like G RPC which is why it's still
around
that's the real-time messaging written
server server push functionality that I
talked about there it also is built on
top of a set of unique protocols that
really formed the basis of signal art in
the original signal there were protocols
under the covers but we didn't really
talk about them we didn't you know
standardized them that we didn't really
document them they were just an
implementation detail of the ACE P net
signal our framework now that we're in
more of a heterogeneous sort of
embracing the heterogeneous world on the
asp net team and we have a sure and we
have services all the type of things we
want Sigma to work with as many things
as possible and so we do have a product
a couple of protocols will talk about
that and that's what really allows
signaler to work these days then we have
this service support for client
addressing and grouping and that's one
of those things that really extends
signal are beyond your typical RPC
framework right you have the ability to
say send a message to this individual
client or to group a series of clients
into a group that you call them and send
them a message you don't get that with a
typical point-to-point RPC framework so
very quick demo here's you know classic
signal our app the Charter app chat are
all signal apps have to have their last
Val remove in order to make them a
signal or app so I'm going to boot this
one up and it just looks like the
standard sort of chat app you would have
seen we demo for signaler for awhile if
your browser is downloading a proxy
script which I'm very happy to so I can
type in here and hit Send and it sends
and comes back from the server all the
type of normal stuff that you would see
and I've got this other button over here
Stream which utilizes a new feature in
signal area nice Burnett core and I can
click that and the server is streaming
information down to me it's going to
count up to 10 in this case now we were
able to do things like this before in
Sigma but because of a spinet core and
we have some new browser output window
stuck there that's super interesting I'm
using David's laptop so if I'm feel like
I'm clunking around a bit that's why so
let's have a look at the server code so
we can all remember and refresh
yourselves what this looks like here's
the really simple part right the send
message on the server is just in a hub
I'd turn around say clients dot all that
send async and that's all I have to do
the stream one is the new one so I'm now
taking advantage of you have turned off
tap having me would like a terrorist
all right that's why I'm struggling so
much we're using the C sharp 8i async
enumerable or async streams feature in
order to very simply allow a client to
call the server and then us stream
information back with a beautiful
awaiting yielding full loop right there
like doing that type of stuff previously
required you to use extra frameworks or
other type of primitives now that stuff
is all kind of built in what does it
look like in the client it's all pretty
straightforward as long as you're happy
and comfortable doing JavaScript that is
the wrong file that's the C sharp file
so you know we've seen this type of
stuff before I've got a bunch of
JavaScript I create a connection up here
on line 35 I'm configuring some logging
so we can see some stuff take place I'm
gonna grab my chat form it's wire up an
event listener check some validity I
actually used like html5 validation and
stuff in here which is kind of cool and
then I go ahead and they do some Dom
stuff like this is all very very
standard type of stuff that you would
have seen when doing any type of client
development I'm not using any frameworks
this is just bare-bones to sort of see
how this stuff works
so that's our super quick refresher on
how signaler works that's all we really
need to get back to in our level of
understanding to understand what we're
going to do the next so we've all seen
in the past how signaler supports
multiple clients I showed you the
JavaScript client just there we also
support different transports so I'm
using WebSockets
but as we've had forever we fall back to
other transports like service and events
and long polling in the cases that we
can't do that and we ship a bunch of
client SDKs we ship the JavaScript SDK
the dotnet SDK the Java SDK there is a
swift SDK that's third-party there's a
Python SDK and we are currently writing
a C++ SDK so we've got all this nice
support on the client and our transport
so what is it that makes that possible
well I mentioned it before we have these
protocols so this flexibility is enabled
by two layers we have a transport
protocol layer which as you can imagine
it defines the set of rules that say
while a client wants to connect to a
server over some type of transport ok
the default one that you usually use too
is HTTP but you can plug in your own
transports if you wish to and there's a
to respect their you can go up onto our
github site you can read the protocol
spec to enhance port and then the second
layer is the hub protocol and that's the
messaging protocol that signaler uses to
support the fact that the client can
call a method on the server and that the
server can call methods on the client
and that gives you all the message types
that you would expect in any type of
protocol so for transports we've all
seen these type of diagrams before a
client connects to the server with long
polling and then the server is going to
wait for an event to take place in that
response back and then the client will
send another request the server sent
events was one of our fallback
transports as well the serve the client
will send a request to the server the
server turns around and then pumps
messages down over that event source
object stream back to the client and we
can get messages that way
WebSockets is the one that we really
want to use right if we're in the
browser we do a WebSocket request to the
server the server says yep that sounds
great let me ever send you back a 101
and we'll switch protocols and then we
can just happily send messages to each
other over that existing TCP connection
wonderful the very first request that
gets sent is a negotiate request before
any of the messages start flowing the
quiet and the server have to agree on
what transport they're going to use and
what protocol our messaging protocol
they're going to use and so we send up a
negotiate request post some endpoint
with a negotiate path and optionally
sending a negotiate version and then the
client the server will respond with the
response with a bunch of metadata like a
connection token and an ID what version
are we can negotiating with and then a
list of transports of the server
supports okay then the client can use
that information then to actually make a
connection to the server here are the
types of messages that are in our
messaging protocol so this is all the
types of messages that are required for
a server to support a client talking to
it with hubs you don't need to know
these you can go to github and read the
spec but if you're going to build a
server like we're going to today you'll
need to understand these different type
of messages so that you can set up a
compliance server so clients can connect
you so why don't we build a server
because I mean we can show slides all
day but I want David not to on stage so
I'm gonna make him write a server in
something other than a dotnet language
Mario you're gonna use go yeah add a
programming go right
nope okay does any want to hear it no
goal who knows go does anyone know so no
one's gonna be able to call him out
anything anyone can do that it's like
you guys kind of data alright I probably
learnt go over the last couple of months
I got super annoyed very well but no
more than you guys service good alright
so let's do a hello world gold just to
everyone's feet wet and warm wet warm
warm and wet
alright let's in the same folder I'll do
a make there dry run this is fully open
BS code yeah
code supports every language pretty much
pretty much on the planet right so I'll
type in the main go here here's my empty
file right easy suffer I'll create a
package is like a an assembly boundary
basically package main here's my main
function isn't doing very much right now
I'm gonna print hello world so fmt print
lying hello world pretty simple so
import her so first dotnet developers
imports relate using I want to import
namespace okay
if MT is the package name okay FME has a
packet method called print' light on it
I'm calling print and I'm printing hello
world pretty simple right on the shell I
can run go run main I should print hello
world right that was quite awful awesome
all right we go developers Oh excellent
yeah if nothing else walk out today see
you've now know how to do hello world
and go alright so that was that was lame
okay let's do hello world HTTP so I can
connect to that with signal on that
right no okay so there's a package
called HTTP in goal framework and go DCL
understand HTTP package where i can call
methods like listen and serve which will
listen on a on a port and address i can
say listen on localhost 8080 five
because that's very specific
for a reason haha I can so far this is
nothing right
it's actually listened to add code for a
specific end point okay so I want a
handle handle funk slash and I wanted to
return hello world I'm gonna do an
anonymous function okay and there's no
type in for single yeah so I have to
actually remember this it is w is a HTTP
dot works response writer and request is
a pointer pointer of HTTP you don't
request not read request request alright
good so far all right now I'm gonna
print hello world so write W dot right
this should be like that they should
probably not be there all right
better write hello world and it won't
work because this is a a byte array this
plus a bite area and I'm passing it or a
byte slice and I'm passing it a string
string right but in go stranger bytes I
can just cast it I should just work Oh
constitutes all wait other way around
buttery right I can cast this to a byte
array I didn't go everything is
backwards so this is an array of bytes
well yeah I was like even your
application of my lambda backwards to
what I'm used to is its forwards because
you your English you're saying W is a
response writer request is a pointer to
replace okay so it's like VB all over
again
oh I mean I mean yeah so if I hit port
80 85 alive okay so we've got two hello
world mr. Ringo we're closer to
connecting the signal a client at this
point yeah I have an ace to the end
point alright first step is to get your
application into Matt's kitchen so you
wrote this thing called chatter yes and
it was in a folder called chatter and
it's supposed to call it the root yes
I'm gonna copy all of it over to here
okay
can I have your entire yeah hey you got
you got all my stuff thing let's rename
this to index okay and then tell go to
serve stomach falls from the group okay
so I can do by the way I have a script
I'm gonna copy and pitch me at some
point I'm just like going for my brain
right now okay so handle slash and I
want to handle all files so file server
and AC Peeta der I'm saying hand serve
files from this folder so here's that
folder but the route the file server
method is returning a handler yep
basically and then that's been possible
handle takes a path and a handler a
Tyler is an interface that has a method
called serve yep sir
takes me requests and a response you can
write though it's like out requests it's
like a request handler in the network
middleware and file server implements
the the serve interface yep and it gives
you a way to specify a directory to
serve files from make sense right so now
I should run this again and I should see
my Damian is beautiful you went to see
boots
way too much time trying to network hey
it's got to be pretty for the people but
Ingo if I hit the actual network
networking start annoys hit look at the
console there's lots of errors yeah so
it requested the negotiate endpoint and
then I said couldn't find it makes sense
right I don't have negotiate endpoint so
we're basically at the first point my
JavaScript code is running I showed you
before signal is trying to make a
connection making the device sheet
request yep ending a 404 because all
you've done so far is write an HTML page
yeah toppy my HTML page
yes copy sorry I'm building on your and
your previous the first step in getting
the protocol to work if you negotiate
endpoint that's correct so looking at
the full protocol to here is the actual
link to the website that has our
protocol description I had described
with a transport protocol has to be
full duplex has to be binary safe has to
be tech safe describes didn't ago she
endpoint the responses for version 1
versus version 0 so we're gonna
implement version 0 response to that
okay
I'm Lizzy who's ever like implemented a
protocol before like look there at the
read an IRC or read some protocol and
they've written code to implement it
like a few hey that's a few people
that's good ok
so I want more clients we want something
fun to do go and try and implement ours
and then give us feedback it is if it's
any good like maybe we need to improve
our protocol it's perfect it's perfect
yeah okay I will let them be the judge
of that based on how well you go in the
next half an hour so I'm going to create
a function called map hub to map my hub
and to not write the thing in Reverse
it's a path or a pathway the string
okay okay path in the string I need to
handle the negotiate method first so
time to start a copypasta okay negotiate
always goes to slash negotiate that's
hard-coded it is okay I believe I have
this thing in
snippet all right hi chichi okay map hub
pretty simple let's do much
here's negotiate I need to copy the
actual struck so in go strikes or battle
strikes verify your types the live on
the stack so I'm declaring two straps
here that will throw my negotiate
response okay and these tags over here
are the attributes so these are like
Jason name is transport lowercase T and
Jason name here is also lowercase
transport formats and then you can also
add things like I want to omit this feel
that if it's no for example so this is
basically an attribute a c-sharp so
thing this has like this other stuff
that can be read out reflection time got
it got it it's just matter they have
yeah a special comment yep it's pretty
gross I love go tell us what you really
think
that's fine nobody have to actually like
handle the ghost yet method so map hub
will hit the string in to the path the
path bit of the actual
signaler connection I'll make the Sigma
hub
chat is the actual hub okay and here's
my negotiate handler which is like slash
chat slash negotiate right where this is
going if you look at the actual error it
should have said /type /annot she ate
right here yep okay got it
is it alright so let's copy-paste this
negotiate handler
so we can have a time to explain it
alright so what did we just do we copied
a bunch of things from my snippets the
first thing is expressive post not a get
or a put her up
if your not post return of 400 it's a
bad client plants doing bad things for
any particular reason we want to post
and certificate no okay alright that's
fine
I think it was because security you want
to plan for hanging a body at some point
okay I think we had a body in the first
version and we removed it
okay reasons the shiny can be any
anything we generate a random crypto
hash for security reasons the connection
ID yep okay so the ID this way well this
what identify your connections for
future use easily I want to talk to that
connection so this is ID and actually
Jen from the server-side the protocol
doesn't specify the format condoning
anything it's just an opaque string
that's right okay so get actually ID
we'll just basics for encode a randomly
generated by Turay okay this is this is
the goal the goal version of new random
new crypto random like generate random
bytes okay this is before encode divider
into a string and then we send JSON
response that map to this truck so this
is this is the equivalent of doing new
negotiate response setting properties
set fields and then setting values and
this returning okay a giant rate make
sense right this is good so far simple
simple all right let's see why our
server doesn't know so I'm not having to
do a ten point I'll be run go and in EDM
does anyone here use edge iam I mean
edge new edge new edge are we supposed
to call it we should have looked at the
marketing material before he can GM make
it a thing edgy edgy you krej is the
other one at hawk I just so bad though
okay all right so I see more success
this time perfect okay more white less
red so negotiate responded with a
beautiful jason response we can see it
got responded here transport WebSockets
that's for a formats text binary
transfer form is basically let you know
if the transport supports text or binary
means pretty obvious here so that's also
new in a snit course again ours we now
support binary message types and so the
transport has
to say yes I can do binary I mean when
you have that because server-sent events
did not support binary so we have to be
able to tell you whether we do it or not
yeah but it tried to connect to the chat
endpoint with the WebSocket hand request
and it get before four okay so
renegotiate now the next step is the
client wants to say yep I'm ready to
send you a WebSocket because you said I
could use WebSockets
yep so it created a WebSocket connection
but that horribly failed because you
haven't written okay okay okay so let's
add some more code now so let's kill the
server all right copy pasta in my public
I'm gonna add some code to handle a
website for the connection is that built
into the HTTP package you were using
already they have a WebSocket thing it
is so there is a WebSocket package as
well that is separate okay yeah after
you recommend using a third party
package because it's a one built in is
probably not good oh okay you always in
the built in one yeah of course so so I
added a handler for the chat the hub
endpoint okay and let's look at the
high-level returns a higher instance
that implements the the handler
interface yep gives me about for a
connection jacket actually get stuff
from the request and response from so if
you had negotiated from the client side
so the client can do in the go she ate
get lady back and then connect with that
idea to WebSockets okay so I've have an
ID I'm gonna send that up with my right
socket connection and pass the other a
string in the query string yep and then
the server I'm assuming that would
usually validate that yes that was the
idea I create for you this is also a
ways they're gonna require sticky
sessions in core because you have to
have had the ID come from this server
it's tight full staple I'm not innocent
okay that request for some period of
time yes there's also a feature in Sigma
Arbor you can do under gonna go she ate
list connection you can connect with an
endpoint directly from the client side
to by plug if and will just work so why
did we bother with doing in the guys
ship is by default in the go she is
because it wants to support flow them
out to the other transports at the
surprise if the client doesn't know
where it's gonna run okay the client has
to be able to negotiate about the other
transport okay so the modern signal a
server does support doing like a single
request connection right thing well you
don't have to negotiate first if you
just both Yolo I'm gonna use WebSockets
can I know because I know it'll work
where do I get my ID from if I don't
negotiate so the color
so the code says get ad from the query
string if it's empty just gen1 oh okay
cool all right all good in the
client-side there's an option called
skip negotiate if you make it true it
just does the actual dirt nice okay but
if you can figure skating ago you
have to say WebSockets only fair enough
so you can't do skip negotiate suckers
is the only one that supports a direct
connection so you need to correlate with
an ID that's right okay so here's our up
luck it handily no no we should be good
to go all right this should work mmm all
right so you have a WebSocket endpoint
now so we would expect to see the
WebSocket request succeed less read more
white okay yeah this is less read okay
so it can be WebSockets it got was happy
it sent the handshake the there's a
handshake that goes from client to
server okay it chose JSON protocol
because that's the default protocol then
it died completely because the goal
server actually wants you to keep this
function around until the socket is dead
so if it doesn't nothing it'll just kill
the whole cache in amino so you have to
start reading from a from the actual
socket
once you go would do that packin action
so I have to write a for loop in here so
let's do I'll just keep copy pasting to
this probably easier I know right so
here's the hash a request
let me get from the client side oh oh
okay so the socket was established yep
and the very next step is someone's
gonna send the message that's right
which end is sending the message the
client the client will send a special
message object message right that's a
signal our message right and that's part
of our transport spec or part of the hub
okay fantastic so we went from from
transport protocol spec right we really
went from not having action to having
one once we have one you flip into the
hub protocols but now we're in the hub
protocol was doing hubs and the hop work
lies about invocations okay and both
dreamers have to negotiate the actual
transport hub protocol right behind
shakes for the very first thing in the
hub protocol is the highest request
okay god quiet stands the hand she's
saying I can do Jason version one and
the server says no stop or yes that's
cool okay and then it sends a handshake
response
if we if we very temporarily print out
what happened let's just do that so then
go there's no well true
there's no while loops there's no do
well there's no for you oh like an empty
for there's a fork there's just one big
one the type yeah those way okay let's
locate that I says I'm gonna read a
message off the WebSocket off the wire
I'll declare a data array of bytes slice
of bytes receive data and then error
handling go is kind of jank see you end
up having to write code like this a lot
get a thing that has an error there's no
exception it's nothing throws and blows
up in your face it's kind of nice okay
also when you save go format rather than
this format your code just destroys this
very opinion it's good it's good it's
good
why is it doing that oh it's killing me
what huh okay hold on there's something
wrong here you've got if at the end
instead of just oh it's not equal to AH
way okay good let me just print this so
FMT that print the print line okay so
you're receiving a message and if there
was an error then you print it's a break
yep I break out okay and then I'm gonna
print the actual data from the client
server so whenever I receive a print on
the console okay so I received then I'll
just cast with shrink is that's cool
assume all bytes or strings is I'll be
doing codings I expect to see some
wing-dings yeah Jason should work
alright so at this point I can just
refresh she got the same right but
there's no more white that's interesting
so the server received the protocol
there's a handshake a football Jason
version one we're good to go
so now we should part the protocol
assume is good because this code is
perfect so this is a handshake doesn't
the climb
expect you to shake back they respond
yeah isn't that the whole point of a
handshake like right now I've done this
I know it's kind of embarrassing I guess
so
we're gonna copy this giant process
handshake function did fail eventually
yeah oh yeah why did it so okay so it
time to time down yeah hey so the client
I did this all right I guess no one's
there all right doorbell no one's home
no one's home tap out okay I'm gonna
copy this process handshake function
which very naively parses the handshake
take one protocol let's actually look at
the protocol in a different browser I
love Ejim but this is a bug this is bug
in the new Chrome diet verifiably the
actual chromium team so it's not a giant
fault oh really
yeah weird WebSocket inspector only
shows one frame Oh oops
so as long as what you want is in the
first message you fine good to go
okay I'm on I'm on the bleeding edge
bits of Aegean that's why it didn't work
it was miss river still running thread
this again so you can actually see the
data being sent over the WebSocket
connection connection there it is there
it is I guess when you sent one thing
but see this this block this super
strange blood that's my wingding you
came through it's awesome so every
single message in the Jason protocol is
permitted by the it's called a record
separator what's a record separator
record separate yeah it's ASCII cool of
30 okay we chose it because we needed to
have a protocol that wasn't bound to a
specific transport we could have said
every single message and Ziggler is
bounced to the WebSocket message that
would be easier I see but to make it
hard for ourselves we want to have our
own format I can left across mobile
transports okay so if you're on TCP
there's no framing so how do you find
the actual end of the message if you
don't have framing need to know this is
the end this is the end of a signal a
message yeah
which means you could have more than one
frame that happen but is it a full
message until you see this actual do you
want to use character turns or line see
it had to be
Jason say you can't put this in Jason
I'd be fun to one then you can open it
isn't okay all right so let's press the
handshake so here's a response here's a
night a parting because we're super
night we're gonna assume that whatever
gets sent that the first thing that gets
sent is the actual protocol the highest
rate request
I mean why even is that actually naive
or is that for perfectly legitimate not
what you would expect the client set a
single by our time oh I see
it would break but who does that who
does that it would do that yeah
a malicious client may be okay for this
code assumes that the thing I got have a
full method I had a full message because
I'm lazy so I got I see I get it I get a
payload and then I look for the 30 which
is the actual record separator okay I
slice here's a slice operation they can
just like say you know get in this an
end so I unmarshal is deserialize so I
allocate a struct ID serialize the
payload into that struct and if there
was an error it's it's the words you
realize and deserialize a.net ism what
does everyone say that I think on Java
this is decirles if Java oh yeah cuz I'm
Marshall sounds I've seen part different
stringify
Marshall unmarshal it sounds more level
it's something more like I'm quoting
sounds scared I'm quoting super hard I'm
muscles Marshall Marshall unmarshal the
protocol isn't Jason return an error
response to the clients are you okay and
to me is Jason oh we're all good okay so
I'm going to run in the handshake
response okay yep so I'm gonna run this
first I'm just say error equals process
presence handshake
WebSockets in the handshake it's good if
like every piece of gold and planet if
air is Michael to nil just awful
just Oh return and print because in case
I want to see the ER yes Prince it okay
okay so this should work now we should
have way less read so in theory now
we'll be able to leave it open and a one
time out it'll just we've done our
handshake and now we're waiting for
something else to happen how many
seconds do we have to wait to be
guaranteed their success
oh okay serve a handshake complete all
right okay handshakes good we're done
okay so can i all right make it fail
again where do something else will suck
it suck it suck it there it is okay
uh-huh no I'm my head you might see from
that's the blood by the way see it
returns whispering means client going to
server and red is server back yep right
okay
and so the server sent back an empty
Jason object yep sure is the handshake
being completed yep okay oh what's that
interesting so the client just tried to
like do something yeah what is it doing
let's find out so when you're lost you
just search for type also we're back in
the spec okay Type six it's a pain a
ping it's the client and server send
pings back and forth to make sure they
the other parties okay okay they're
right this was the client because it was
green yeah it was gonna quietly I think
of the server side okay and if we're
lucky they sent two things
whoo and at some point it gets angry and
says you know what I'm not pinging me
you're offline okay so signal are
includes a ping-pong kind of thing
basically apologies pink just pings
but is their only client to server or
just the server sender ping as well in a
good server not your server yeah and the
good server says penis both directions
okay and so the client is basically
trying to make sure that the connection
is actually alive be great you never
trust what your connection API is
telling you go through a tunnel of your
connection you go up on a plane yep you
fly through our knowledge fly through a
tunnel a black hole okay I think we are
working black hole sorry once the two
pings basically don't get a reply the
client says nope this connection is not
good
isn't just Pink's it's any messages and
emails when you get sent if things
haven't been sent in that time for okay
okay all right so we need to get the
server to respond mm pink all right we
need to add our own pinging let's do
that let's do that let's do that
there's things here's my super fancy
ping logic
what what's the ping timer what's the
timing it expects I mean seconds some
protocols specify if in the code summer
no okay
the client decides went to to diabase on
a threshold I think our default is like
if you haven't seen it at least two
pings in like 30 seconds okay 30 seconds
that's the default yeah we figure it
yeah you can we tried more aggressive
numbers and it kind of broke people so
we kind of went conservative by default
said so it dies at some point but it's
not super aggressive okay you can tweak
it to be whatever you want on the client
side so here's a ping er so in.net you'd
create a new timer new timer has a
callback that gets called every whatever
seconds you passed into it
in the call bot he would just like write
doing something there right right super
simple ish until you learn how it works
right this is the goal version you
create ticker and and go there there
aren't that many primitives so the
pattern you see a lot is channels so a
challenge is a basically think of it as
an is ignorable you can actually read
from or write in - okay so I create
ticker I'm gonna run every 10 seconds
and I made a channel of bull just don't
ask why this is here yet here's an
infinite loop and it says whenever the
ticker fires run this callback so I'm
casting over the actual channel firing
are done being sent okay
they fire an anonymous coroutine in line
this actually this this is TAS not run
combat yeah this is tango okay I'm
ticker is basically this is basically a
a weight for each have you guys seen the
icing and durable powdered in c-sharp
yeah well I showed it in the chat
oh yeah wait for each is equal weight
for each tick and
ticker okay right this code does that
okay
all right take your word for it cuz no
one in here knows guys it's perfect we
can come you all right at the end
take it out stop and I'm gonna write a
bull into the done channel ah she's
super super janky synthetics you're
putting something into the channel
that's why you're doing some right
yeah okay so it's a challenge on the on
this side you're reading from it this
side being what side the there right
there looking at it this for right I'm
putting true into done okay pushing it
in like forcing it in all right so now
this should give me a stable connection
a stable one thing so this should not
timeout okay let's look at crome and
just stare for like half an hour maybe
deja vu I think last year we had a
signal a demo and recall that we spent a
lot of time waiting for something to go
wrong middle at all
it's because oh okay there we go
all right oh okay two pink spin but one
of the first one was red yeah that mean
the server was sending one day ah every
ten seconds the service end the pain and
every something the client's of thing oh
I can't I just got I think you said this
before in the punk each side is just
sending messages each side is just
saying if I don't see anything from the
other side in a time period I'm just
gonna assume that you nicked off yep
okay got it got it
alright cool stable let's try you
actually use the question oh let's do an
invocation okay that didn't work so on
the server side we received the
invocation but nothing is handling it
okay right so the handshake happened
sending things back and forth we're
stable no and nobody actually handle it
so my generation that I wrote defending
a message to say please call this method
but you're going you're just ignoring it
you know what I'm saying
cool cool Tori you're throwing it away
yeah well the client fail it does
hangover alright yeah alright so let's
sounds like if it looks like we're close
yeah this feels right some more copy and
paste a movie done soon all right so
we're gonna copy this these two types
hug message and how about his
implication to the top of the file
because that's clean every message and
the Jason hub protocol has a type
property it tells you what type is being
about type six is paying type 4 is
whatever I want is implication
and then an implication message which is
type what is it me for type 1 has a
bunch of specific fields like the target
which is the method being invoked the
implication ID which is an ID so the
client can correlate responses from the
server-side right so I book with with
implication 0 you sent to the server
side the server wants to respond with a
value the server will say implication
zeroes response is this ok then
arguments are a bunch of Justin
arguments
please show method you're calling on
spawn so let's finally at the point will
be doing the IPC base okay here's our PC
okay little let's hustle so here's the
man loop I'm gonna copy this codes
slash it into right here by implication
you want more snippet this one you're
printing your message is twice I think
now yeah yeah good alright so on receive
we find the record separator ASCII code
30 sliced a byte array get the raw hub
message deserialize into the actual one
that has a type only this is kind of
inefficient but it works
I get the type if it's one that I know
it's an implication so I do it again but
using the Raman the full message right a
sense sorry so you need to be able to
parse to know what type it is you need
to know the title copper t eating just
to see you read just the type I see you
figure out this 1 to 6
I knew parse the actual concrete type
based on that number got it I'm excited
I just get the invocation and we call it
on implication method there's nothing
right now right and to make it do
something very basic we should actually
respond with the completion response and
the completion response is in the spec
and it's type 3 and it says here is the
type 3 which is a completion and the
application ID but which I'm completing
and it can't have an error or it can't
have a result okay but it cannot both
failure this is the answer to my a piece
equal support a call violation yep okay
that's right it can be no if you're
avoiding I'm not returning anything okay
it can be no it's lawyer forget type of
thing not for I forget no no just void
this void okay I see
it's still a response some response but
nothing is in it right so you've got it
so here's the invocation and we're going
to do a basic completion Act so I'll
copy this logic into here this is
nothing it's funny this is actually a
compiler if you drop a trillion comma oh
wow
holy all right
this shouldn't make the implication
return nothing nothing
well so back to our protocol test here's
a response ah
clients happy but nothing happened but I
didn't get a message
no okay nope so let's make this work
note so now we're at the point where the
client was able to call like my hub
method yep but in my other example the
hub method was turning around saying
clients all dots end right but we
haven't written that part yet and go
right and so the clients like yeah I
sent a message but now we need to do the
pushpot correct so ever needs to push
this to all the clients and it's
important to know that the protocol
doesn't dictate the actual grouping are
broadcasting or I send to a client he's
just talking about what happens between
client and server right so I call a
method on the server side the server can
decide to return a result yep broadcast
everyone broadcast to a group not
returnable all I doesn't know nothing no
routes or anything it's just like I got
a message just know it was in a group
due to the protocol right right that
soul says also recited for detail that's
right so let's make it do so I had this
thing to make it reply to wanna
connection but maybe we shouldn't make
it reply to both all that once this time
is short go also does not have a ternary
operator you can't just and go say like
you can't do question mark you can't do
or not equal to no right this doesn't
work and go that's unfortunate someone
if I do this this is like horrific right
okay
let's implement reply to one connection
that's what happened as the first step
so the first step is you're literally
just going to turn around and make sure
this message is sent to the per
to me okay right but it's not in the
reply that's right just I'm pushing
another man this is an invocation the
same pan sent to the server side the
client supports implication so I can
send them back to the client and
invocation saying I'm gonna echo your
incoming with an arguments about client
side okay so this guy says if target is
sent I'm gonna create a replay type one
is in location target is sent I'm
calling sent on the client side I'm
gonna echo the same argument I passed
into the actual server side okay it's
almost like echo this is why you're
really doing an app yep yet go if I run
this this should echo it to myself oh
wow yeah look claps tough we're doing
that half crowed were you doing the
heading go guys can you show the traffic
yeah were you doing that did you send
the the message to the client before you
sent the ACK or did you send it after
the ACK good question and does it matter
before it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter okay yeah because the whole thing
is like asynchronous is nothing matter
that's right okay so oh it went through
this guy but didn't go to this this
other browser cuz they're not looking at
being broadcast right so you did send it
to the client before you sent the client
the reply from the original message
that's right because I can see in the
log okay but I can't get that did you
see like the order of operations there
okay with the client isn't broadcasting
so this browser isn't the same as that
browser there's no there's no I'm gonna
brush each person is chatting with
themselves right mhm okay can we make
them so they can talk to each other
that's right this is fun chat okay where
everybody's right this is like when you
get shadow band right in Xbox Live so
you're talking you everyone else what
we're gonna do here is declare a
concurrent dictionary equivalent and go
which is a sync map so I'm gonna declare
a thing to try the clients clients
equals to sink top map No
I'm gonna pass it by reference we don't
want a copy of it okay yeah if you learn
girl you have to remember all this stuff
see you see sure so ampersand was
referenced and the star was a pointer
that's right so I need a point of doing
that because what they happen if a
pathway value yeah and I mutate the
object Oh guess what happens okay no one
knows it's a copy it's a copy of the
object so you wouldn't happen it
wouldn't actually I didn't see it okay
clients uh store connection ID so I'm
mapping in the connection ID I'm storing
the ID to the websocket itself so I
didn't have a list of WebSockets by D so
just a dictionary just a prediction yep
and there is the ID and then the actual
connection is the value but it stops
I'll just client start remove no it's
not delete delete' connection ID and
then I'll pass this into the invocation
of possibly reference okay why it's no
make sure I have this be client is this
pointer of sync that and right here the
syntax is kind of weird get ready for
you might be blowing with a bizarre
syntax so this and go is a cast
it looks bizarre but it's super nice so
the value is an object it's like an
object oh you can do it in line like
left to right right yeah so interface is
the equivalent of object this is like an
interface wouldn't with anything right
and then I'm doing a cast - I plug a
connection because I know the value is
like much like a connection got it and
doing it this way absol it's me dot and
keep casting and dotting that link like
a C and C sharp requires LIGO wrapping
around Renta sees like this or you can
do an expose this and the cast this is
no generics like you have to pass it
through as an object because you can't
just you know do nothing to sync maps of
T another thing pretty bad okay yeah
that's why does it make you feel dirty
yeah
100% what is it saying I can't do here
cuz you made it Bella this is there a
pointer haha alright so we should have a
fully working application if I'm not
mistaken oh no we don't get it actually
it's good enough yeah yeah even I'm your
first yeah good so we have two choices
we can make streaming work or we could
now I do slides and then I just want to
reiterate though like we literally took
a functional a spinet course signaler
app where we use the a spinet course
signaler api on the server i use the
JavaScript client and then we took the
entire client part and then you wrote a
hard coded chat server it uses the
signaler protocol in go it's not a
generic signal a server like if you want
to go and add another hub it's not like
you just add a type and then call a map
method correct right you have a
hard-coded server that's built
specifically for this chat app but the
client just thinks it's a signal server
that's right that's pretty cool all
right
no iswe think I think it's cool you
think it's cool I think it's cool yeah
well if they're cool it's fun alright so
you built a server and go well so
there's a bunch of stuff you didn't do
yeah because it's just a hard-coded demo
right but what happens if like threads
occur or whatever like what does that
mean it's not thread safe what you did
so the pings are running in probably the
actual like other nothing is gonna
synchronize okay let's lock it right
okay I should be locked I see but for
the sake of two clients that turns out
it's pretty safe okay there's no error
handling really had a lot of if
statements but you're not doing anything
using it with them other than printing
into the console there's no grouping so
they no because that is very much like I
said some part of the protocol the
grouping thing is just really part of
our server API and our server
implementation so I mean you could add
that yep but you didn't do it there's no
client to server streaming we could do
server to Terminal class streaming
server the client streaming which should
just be another for loop is my guess
with a timer that's right yeah so it
wouldn't be too hard and there's no
concept of cancellations so in sync
today the protocol actually supports
cancelling an invocation you didn't do
that although you know if the client had
tried to say cancel this the server just
would have gone all right cool then this
is frame interleaving what does that
mean well if we think about the two
layers going on here we've got our
transport frames which in this case were
WebSockets right so we have a WebSocket
each of these orange boxes is a
WebSocket frame or message and they can
be of different sizes right and this is
per transport they all define how they
send their messages according to their
spec then we have on top of that the hub
messages or the hub frames from the hub
protocol and they don't necessarily
align with the transport frames now this
is just like you can have Ethernet
frames and then on top of that you can
have tcp/ip frames and then on top of
that you can have and I'm generalizing
so his network wants like you can know
afterwards and then you can have HTTP
messages on top of that and they don't
all line up perfectly like things get
chunked and they get correlated
according to the rules of the layout now
it turns out that doing it from a
browser makes it a little easier because
WebSockets in browsers when you call
right it pretty much guarantees it's
always gonna be in one frame gonna help
me because I he'll be right there
because of how we wrote it how we wrote
the client okay so you didn't have to
worry about it but as you can see
sometimes in the real world in real
implementations they don't line up and
you have to deal with that so for
example I could have a WebSocket
transport frame which has a header with
a bunch of bytes that mean things and
then my actual message payload and then
I could have a JSON ping which we saw
right type equals six and then this
other message could be my non-blocking
invocation message and so like you have
to deal with that in a real signal a
server otherwise it will be horribly
unreliable so what about scale out we
know we've done lot to talk to about
scale out in the past this is a typical
diagram you'll end up seeing we have all
of our clients here and in order to
support more clients we had more servers
but then we have the problem of how does
client number one talk to client number
four when they're on a different server
well then you have to add another layer
which is the backplane all the way on
the right-hand side and then you know
the server's all connected the backplane
and they can coordinate messages and
send them to each
we still support that that's all
supported today we ship a Redis a
backplane implementation I think the
only one we ship now yeah that's all
good good and well then we also have
this great thing now the outer signal
our service which David was a big part
of architecting and so this provides
signal a scale out as a service as a
platform service you know you get a
subscription and your app connects to it
and then you've got scale out but it
also doesn't just do the backplane part
it offloads the signal or connections
from the client out of your application
you don't have to worry about having a
web socket endpoint in your a spinet
core app anymore you'll go out they get
handled by the paths by the platform
as-a-service
okay and then like magic happens that
correlates those messages back into your
application and that's fantastic for
scale because now you've got to scale
units you've got your web application
with your MVC and your pages and your
hub code but all your web sockets are
actually connecting over on this other
thing and you can scale them
independently you're not using up HTTP
connection resources on your web app
that's all being paid for and scaled
separately in the azure signaler service
so it relays that client traffic to and
from over a couple of web sockets
between your application and the service
so here's like how your app starts
you've got your client that's connecting
to your a spinet core app you've got web
track traffic going to like pages or MVC
views and then you've got your web
socket or signaler connections going up
to you to your hub right and that's all
in one blue box you can only scale the a
spinet core app as a unit you can't
split those two things apart but then if
you deploy it to add your signal or
service your app now connects over to
the signal server sort of within the
data center right over that black
two-way arrow that's some dedicated
connections between your application on
the server side and the ads of signaler
service and then the clients sort of
gets split personality they go over and
connect all the web sockets over to the
client endpoint and but they happily
keep doing their web traffic over to
your ace minute core app which is
fantastic and then this is what it looks
like when you add more clients they're
all connecting their web sockets to the
client endpoint on the edge of
signalized service you never see them
you don't have to worry about them that
it all gets taken care of by the signal
or service and then you're a spinet core
connects to the server end point which
is private to you and then you get an
in-memory representation of all the
clients currently connected to you the
signaler co doesn't know any different
your hub code doesn't know any different
you just say clients don't all dot Send
and in memory it goes yeah I've got six
clients send those please and then those
messages actually go over one of these
pipes to the server and then the
signaler service is the one that figures
out where they go okay and those clients
could be connected all over the world
you just don't have to worry about it so
it completely solves an entire category
of problem that is traditionally very
very difficult to solve with regards to
scaling sockets basically all right and
then one of the things that enables is
this completely new programming model
servlet who's using Azure functions or
AWS lamdaur or something like that okay
so with a thing like the signaler
service you can now build real-time or
server push applications without you
having an ace pin air core application
there's no asp net in this whatsoever
there's no app I've deployed there's no
traditional signaler server I just have
a client in this case it's changing an
out of storage blob that fires an event
grid event to my as a function which
handles the event grid event and it
turns around and posts a message via the
rest endpoint to the edge of signaler
service which then broadcasts whatever
on my actual function wants to to all
the connected signal our clients and
there are people building apps like this
today it is actually basically
officially supported by Azure functions
working in conjunction with the signal
or service so could we build that no no
yeah so do them so we just went through
the whole benefit of being able to
offload your WebSocket connections on to
a totally different server can we make
that work so you know four minutes four
minutes so instead of doing it from
scratch
I'll probably just record a rose I'll
show that kind of explain yeah it works
right so I I'm going to open an
application I wrote that uses
okay okay so here's a basic if that core
segment application okay another chat
app yep but different actually I'm gonna
copy it does - yes I didn't try
that and the startup plus it's very
similar it has this call to add a just
ignore that's the only difference
right is that my a spinet core app now
is saying you signal a but I want you to
use the as your signal a service load
that's it
they were the difference right so I have
installed the vanilla roger Sigma SDK
okay no tricks up my sleeve nothing
crazy I did this because this is the
reasons okay I will mention and the chat
hub is the same hub right two methods
yep send a stream all the people right
and I wrote this and if I look at the
app settings normally you go to the add
report 'l you would create a new
subscript and you I'll just ignore
service and get a connection string that
contains little your secret key and
you're like endpoint address okay so
like my app that's still going on done
that it's Ziggler service endpoint yeah
but what if I could just point to the
local host I don't say port is this
right you're telling the standard as a
signal service client where to connect
it's a point to my local figma looking
at point to you right fake one right so
I wrote wanted go for fun it's a fun fun
to profit because that's what we do here
it is here's my Sigma or my address
signal our server so before I show you
the code let me run it to make sure it
works still works all right Phil - your
signal are go run main let go then if I
launch this application
should connect to that end point and it
says connected if I launch I want to
scroll probably I can show you the
actual thing happening if I go to
localhost five dozen which is my yeah
attic off your beautiful application but
here is the initial negotiate request to
my application okay they returned a
response that said instead of going to
my application go to the Sigma service
that's how it works
so in negotiating request can actually
respond with yeah this is fine but
actually what you did negotiate over
here instead and this is how right
offload those connections over to
another service so the Sigma service
gives you gives you an access token for
this signal or you're gonna hit a mine
is hosted local wave security security
security security tokens the URL points
the client endpoint the server goes to
the server end point there's a plan
points on the actual goal server my
figler server yep do I see there's a
documented protocol for the application
to service right communication they
implement that's on a different github
repository somewhere that you can write
ok
and if I type test this should work
right here's my actual service and
traffic is actually going to my go
application not my main application so
if I look higher negotiate happens on
the main server on five thousand on five
thousand comes back goes to eighty eight
eighty seven which is a segment of
service ok connects to that server
directly with this giant query string
yeah and then from then on it's just
ignore business just send stuff I can
work through that service can you it
will will to clients work that's right
that's right let's do this
so now my age minute core app is still
running because it served this
incredibly beautiful page that you wrote
that's right
and but then after that it only handles
the negotiate requests the first one and
then that reply is no no go and connect
your web socket over here and right
that's it doesn't really know anything
until the service calls are back and
says someone hit Send
that's right here's the message yep and
then the server runs and says your
server runs and says yeah ok class let's
send all and then that goes back to the
service and broadcasts to all the
clients even better the service itself
is actually understand Sigler it just
proxies traffic from the client and
point to the server endpoint awesome
alright practice lesson we had done just
like touch well ok so hopefully we've
gotten
a good indication about how signal works
under the covers today hopefully you can
see why the edge of signal service might
be a benefit to you if you're trying to
run this stuff in scale there's a code
available for people good essay will be
it will be by the end of the day yes
okay well thanks for coming along if
you've got any questions you can reach
out to both of us on Twitter and have a
great conference Cheers
[Applause]